here's what all conspiracy theories have
in common there are people who are sure
something is
true that they want to be true every
single one of them I've yet to find an
exception to this they find evidence in
support of what they want to be be true
or if there's evidence that points
against it they have to invoke a
conspiracy to keep believing what they
want and say the missing evidence was
taken by the government so that they can
continue to believe what they want well
people don't like to say I don't know I
love to say I don't know the universe
brims with Mysteries and all those UFO
sighting I don't know what they are
let's investigate them if I'm in
argument with somebody I don't say I
don't know I'm just like oh yeah and I
try to bend it to to win the argument
why do you have to win every argument
what what's wrong with you ego
based